[Musique]
la doyenne de l'humanité vient de fêter
ses cent soixante neuf ans l'âge le plus
avancé jamais atteint par l'homme on
attend plus de 4 milliards de personnes
ce soir pour fêter ce sens 69e
anniversaire 99 ans de plus loin du
compte
justice aux gentils staff on me fit
anime la pure vérité
[Musique]
la cause de la mort est la même pour
tous tir à bout portant sur la tempe
droite
ceci est le signe d'appartenance à une
cellule pro suicide écoute je vais pas y
aller par quatre chemins j'ai besoin de
toi je suis un stand cikotic je disais
que cette violence les 270 a disparu
durant une heure et demie c'est nous
tous ceux qui se régénèrent mal ou peu
pas gagner dans ce cas crever alors que
vous êtes tous obsédés par l'idée qu'ils
votent baratin pour justifier ces motifs
ne serait pas commencer par le bilan
t'étais un fantôme
on stigmatise toute une frange de notre
société bientôt on s'étonne que certains
mineurs se radicalise
pas de penser pas d'excès c'est ça
qu'ils veulent mais on n'est pas commune
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça peut [ __ ] qui se font
tomber
la vérité même si personne n'ose pas
dire ce qu'on n'a plus besoin d'enfants
[Musique]
je passe savoir du coup ça trompe pas
depuis le début